e
e e
yeah I thought I had it
on wow that's
good
yeah well thank you very much there's
also this copy right here
does everybody have a copy of this up
front here okay so I'll take the copy
I'll I can take one of couple of
those what I think I had that one last
week
school yeah I know I've had so many
versions of
this okay I'll start it out
um
I over the last week or so since we've
been given this side by side online and
I struggle to make my own
copies I've sort of struggled looking at
the rules here I look at page one page
two three by the time I get to page six
my mind's ready to
explode and I basically have hit the
wall um so what I'd like to do today is
try to if we can to look look at this in
terms of what are some of the takeaways
we're we're getting from this uh the
either the pluses or the minuses seeing
that we have a responsibility to make
recommendations regarding all academic
standards in areas which are referen
within these rules which impact those
and also 193
e2a so
um with that I'd like to just quickly go
through some of the definitions which we
had so so we can have some further
discussion here since we've had this
given to us the discussions of the the
definitions on pages on on the copy that
I printed out is about like pages one
through five
thereabouts um so it's just the first
several Pages here that we can look
at one of the takeaways that I've taken
here is that's um there number of
statutory
definitions which been included
Within These proposed rules which are
contrary to statute that's written and
been adopted by the general court signed
into
law and I think we need to address those
that that as a as an
issue um starting right out uh on that
on 3061
is there anybody let's just quickly go
through this um applicability in order
to be an improved school public schools
and publicy shall meet the applicable
criteria establishing these standards
any issues with
that
area let's go on the next one then
except as provided in B below a public
school shall be approved as an
elementary school if it contains any of
the grades kindergarten through 8 and
Mees the rules applicable to all schools
and to each elementary school and you
can see what they have changed that
too except as provided in C below a
public school shall be approved as now
met school if it contains kindergarten
through 8 and meets the rules applicable
to all schools and to each Elementary
School believe it or not I was hit up at
the Grafton County budget meeting by a
representative regarding this one
itself so um Mr chair uh ju just going
back to the the first part A yeah um so
there is a change on that because it's
added to be an approved school
so this is just a question is that
setting up then a distinction between
public schools and
publicy and approved
schools so said another way um would it
be all right for public schools and
public cies and publicy not to meet
these this applicable criteria and
therefore not be an approved
School represent this going to be a long
day no no but I mean I but you hear what
I'm saying though right I I got it I get
you that it it it's it's changing it
from public schools and public acmis
shall meet the criteria to only shall
meet the criteria if they want to be an
approved School
well what you see the way it was in the
original I'm looking back in what we had
back in
2014 says in order to be an approved
school they put that first public
schools and public academies shall meet
the applicable criteria establishing
these standards I think I think we ought
to revert right back to what we have
absolutely I agree with you yeah is
there any objection to that by anybody
here so we'll make a note to Star the as
it was yeah okay the next one down
their
change this was pointed out by
representative fellows at the Grafton
County meeting to me just on money and
we weren't even talking we were talking
budget but she jumped this quickly
contains kindergarten through eight and
meets the rules what about a school is
like the little blue School up in Landa
which is K through
three doesn't it doesn't have four five
six seven
eight so they're changing it from if has
any of these grades any of the grades to
must have k through
eight well they're
saying as an elementary school if it
contains kindergarten through
eight so now what happens if it doesn't
contain kindergarten through grade8 what
happens if it only contain kindergarten
through grade three like the little blue
school I have a couple of schools like
that oh yes they're all over the state
sprinkled everywhere if you go down to
part C the former part C or what's now
the part C they keep that language where
it says contains any of the grades 9
through 12 so in
part in the part we're discussing right
now I think we should just leave the L
that strike
through so leave as is okay we'll start
that
too and going
down to the next one down there as
determined by the vote of the local
school board any combination of grades 4
through 8 may be organized as a public
middle school and so approved if it
meets the rules applicable to all middle
schools right now it is grades 4 through
eight could be a middle
school that's there's no change
according to uh G the attorneys you see
on the right hand side no change so
we're leaving it right there where it
is jumping down to where representative
Pell just
mentioned um
um this has no
change that that was the point I was
making they didn't change it down there
but they changed it in the yeah previous
session
okay so we're no change we're good with
that I guess then um 306 6.02
definitions uh academic standards has
defined in that
RSA and it says new
definition added so it's added to the
minimum standards and they're taking the
RSA number that's where we reference
academic standards what you need to know
and be able to do
okay with that adding it in there
academic standards it's it's it's what
the RSA
reads I think the minimum standards do
contain reference to academic stat and
Slater so we ought to have that
definition in the minimum standards for
public school
approval da you okay with that um I'm
just trying to understand what um so
so a is not new language is
it no but it's new to the I don't let's
see let's look see if it's in the old
standards
here no it's not they're adding it to
the
standards if you look at this book right
here the one which is right there from
14 they're not listed in it okay so now
what they're saying we need to list that
in
the academic standards means academic
standards as defined in statute yeah so
I have no problem with that because
that's what's in statute okay we're good
with
that okay the next one down
acknowledgement of achievement means
when a student has demonstrated
achievement of District competencies and
or grad graduation competencies
consistent with rsa's 193c col
3 this is where I start getting gut AES
um we have this great discussion going
on regarding the words
proficiency Master
competencies
um got to be
careful I had done some work here on
that
um and this this is a
new see revised language rumed
do you see their proposed language
there so they're changing
acknowledgement of achievement to a
achievement of competencies
see what I had written If I Were King of
the Heap here I'd write it something
like this acknowledgement of achievement
occurs when the student has demonstrated
Mastery of key content specific Concepts
skills and
knowledge and that's pursuant to RSA 193
H 1 Roman
2 but I'm not King at
hate to me proficient means that yeah
you're okay you don't have you haven't
mastered it you don't have a complete
understanding of it you just sort of
have the basics that's what proficiency
me is yeah and I would like to see this
stronger
proficiency and Mastery are different
terms I I agree 100% Senator with you on
that you
know is proficiency Mastery no
performance level targets that lead to
Mastery we have levels of Mastery so you
have levels of proficiency as you're
moving towards that
um you look at the definition
competencies that's in RC 193 H1 why
don't we take a look there because they
there's a second sentence there
underneath competencies which deals with
Mastery you say 193 what
H
one I didn't bring my rigger one here so
I got no tabs
here see it says competencies mean
student learning targets that represent
a level of mastery
and it goes on specific and required
types of compeny include District
competencies at grade level in in course
or program compes etc
etc then if you if you got your books if
you're looking at that you can go over
to 193
H1 d a the
purpose and you see in Roman 3 where it
says students best learn at their own
pace as they Master content and skills
allowing them to advance when they
demonstrate the desired level of
Mastery so we we've done referencing to
Mastery in statute
so um so Mr chair are you you suggesting
that the definition of competencies and
D should line up with the definition of
competencies in 193
H1 yeah if if if if we're going to have
it already in Statue of course we should
line it up yeah and you know and I think
that equate the word Mastery to if
you're going have your roof on the house
repair you're going to look for a
master construction worker to put a roof
on because everything you own is
underneath
it proficient means there's different
levels of you can be proficient but not
a master at it right I think it's
important that we set the bar for every
kid as we want them all to try to
towards Mastery there will be on the
assessments different levels of
proficiency that we see some might below
some be some might be above proficient
above proficient is probably closer to
Mastery but Mastery of you have Mastery
of a course a course credit there are
courses that are embedded in a program
of studies like mathematics T Cal
algebra so you you can
Master algebra but doesn't necessarily
mean You' have mastered all your math
right
right and and would it would it also be
fair to say that there are competencies
that that you would um and I want to
make sure I get the
right term um rep uh competencies that
you master within a within a course but
that's not to say that you've mastered
everything in the course right and I
think that's what competencies in a
definition we've been competencies means
you've attained these targets
learning targets along the way so like a
flight path you have benchmarks along
the way targets M um Master is at the
end of that right but you may have
Mastery in that
particular area within that course maybe
Grant you time
Stables don't have achieved problem
solving yet they haven't apped them
right right
so I'm having difficulty with this uh
I'll be truthful with you I I think that
we're asking our teachers in the field
to really
start managing this thing down to the
nitty-gritty and I can remember going
through this in the late 70s and the 80s
we had teachers spend more time
managing and checking all the boxes with
little Susan Jones here is Master the 70
competencies associated with this and
less time
instruction MH and I think we're sliding
and are we going back and trying to
repeat exactly what we found we changed
that we had to get away from
that it's important that you as the
teacher have that in your head you're
certified to teach reading you know what
she doesn't have um and that's what
you're getting paid the big bucks to do
yeah yeah yeah magnificent instruction
so
um so that was acknowledgement of a che
m not the definition of a competencies
that's later
on but um and they're changing to
achievement of
competencies so you put in the D in here
right from the
uh that that the from
H1 is that the one you want uh on page
one of this thing here I I guess I'm
walking away from it a little bit and I
in looking I'd like to have
acknowledgement of achievement occurs
when the student has demonstrated
Mastery of a key content specific
Concepts skills and
knowledge uh that's echoing the RSA 193
H 1 Roman 2 I
referenced we can put a question mark
there I mean what what happens when
there's um when there there is an
agreement between what's in a rule and
what's in the statute
say that again please so like ju just
taking for example the definition of
competencies um it's defined in Statute
in each one and it's defined in rules
um totally
differently I guess I have a similar
question because there's no definition
of achievement of competencies in
statute is there no it now it reads
accomplishment of
achievement and they're changing
achievement to
competencies or achievement of
Competency acknowledgement of
a well it's a achieving those learning
targets that represent a level of
Mastery and that's in the definition of
Competency
level
it's level of Mastery of content
specific concept skills and knowledge
applied within or across content domains
so in the H1
definition um Mr chair it it talks about
um means student competency competencies
means student learning targets that
represent a level of Mastery so is
proficient a level of
Mastery I think this a lot of levels of
M no but is it a level of M I
mean uh you can be proficient at a level
of one of these targeted areas that
leads to Mastery
of of what you're
learning you're saying that as a as a as
a
practitioner being a former principal
and and superintendent
and teacher and teacher but what what is
it what does it say in the rules and
statute well right now it says right we
have an acknowledgement of achievement
that's what we
have oh
man acknowledgement of achievement means
when a student has demonstrated
achievement of District competencies and
the state doesn't set District
competencies right you may establish the
bar higher in Hopkinton and you set
those competencies
and Andor graduation conferen is
consistent with RSA 193
C3 the graduation diploma is issued by
the school district not by the
state well except I know it except the
the state can provide a certain number
of credits to that um towards that
graduation independent of District
competencies see what what there if if
you look at the sheet later on it deals
with
Mastery um on the sheet that I have and
I think you Ruth that's page
five um it deals
with um I see on the new sheet
it's it's one two 3 four five pages in
the same I guess they're the same on the
bottom there it's highlighted under
proposed unapproved revisions
Mastery means a high level of
demonstrated proficiency with regard to
ACC
competency so um Mr chair yeah just um
because I think at at this rate we will
be here forever um and may maybe maybe
what just a suggestion um as far as
accomplishment for today is just go
through the side by side and you know
what we don't have to comment on any of
things just just try to understand
what's what's in front of
us and we can go through the side by
side and um
and
yeah I I think that we need to have a
thorough discussion this competencies
proficiency and Mastery with the
department and
and and Ure
that I I I just think we're just on the
verge of moving things around totally in
terms of Education here I think we got
to be very careful yeah because
traditionally I believe in the
traditional meaning of competencies that
it's the knowledge skills Concepts and
work study practices that are required
to achieve a desired level of
Mastery other words I look at that high
bar and then you have different levels
of proficiency along the way of getting
there or even a high proficiency when
you achieve that m master I think that's
exactly what is saying on the fifth page
here uh commenters request that
proficiency be changed to
Mastery definition of Mastery and
current rules Mastery means the student
performance required to achieve at least
85% of a competency that's all new
stuff and so are you going to have a
teacher now figure out okay what kind of
instrument are you going to give me to
assume that that child makes
85% mhm in a simple Mastery of how to
identify a dip
Tong or a blend or a vowel or a
consonant we need to have a discussion
with them and we need to figure out
where we're going with
this I know the the third party that was
contracted is moving wants to move in
that competency Direction
maybe good idea I don't know but we
we've been doing that for the last
years I think that contract got extended
another year today oh really yeah oh
executive Council into 2025 yeah well
that's because these rules have a 10e
2015 to
25 that's what I would assume okay let's
move on now then so put question mark
there by that
right there and we need to discuss this
thing about these three terms
MH uh Career and Technical education
means organize educational activities
that and then lists them
um that right there has been revised
language to reflect the existing
statutory definition and they say
removed the and the way that's in law if
you if you look at that RS say 188
e23 you can see that they're using part
of the definition
to Roman
3 there it is on page
409 see it says current technical
education or CTE means organized
educational activities that then you
have an
a well a one and a two under and three
underneath a and a b is that all part of
the
definition I would say yes too with it
they're not putting it all in there so
they're removing all that they're
removing part of it
um um yeah they're removing it they're
removing it all of
it they're removing it but they're
referencing the statue that's not okay
by me either Patty it's this is forer
attack yeah well they remove it but they
reference the statute
rather than listing it
all if they if they're going to do that
would they have to put after Roman
A 1 2 3 B
or a plus
b or can you do it reference to just
Roman three I guess you
could but they say they're removing
it well they're REM langu to reflect
existing statutory definition okay yeah
if they wanted to keep it in they would
have to
reference the a one 2 3 and b i they
would have to reference it up here you
can see the jail car recommendation yeah
use exact statory
term or CTE Career Technical education
or
CTE
okay okay I guess if they're going to
have referencing the RSA I'm good with
that
you're going to keep us in the
present you're going to keep us in the
present statue yeah
so we'll just reference that statute and
and then it would take everything right
down to
here
okay want to go on next one
yeah
okay I guess it's College and Career
Readiness
removed paragraph C
that's in the
current they're just taking it
out any problem with taking that out
um why is it in there right now
I honestly don't know where um where
where is it in the current rules it's
right
where they're taking it
out right here if you look at
it we have a copy of this um we should
have a copy of that that's when I I'll
see if I have any other copies in the
office
first
yeah sure
it's it's in
you we keep that down there I don't have
any others com off well we we can we can
pass it pass sit along you just send it
down to Patty I I I guess I guess the
question I would ask is why is it why is
it
out well you know the
the the first question would be why is
it in there now and if College and
Career Readiness as a term is used
elsewhere in the rules yeah then it
makes sense to have it defined yeah if
it's not used elsewhere in the rul it
doesn't make any difference yeah um
but if if somehow it was used elsewhere
in the current rules and then that was
taken
out you know yeah when I that would be
concerning when I reviewed this earlier
I jumped over that it didn't give me a
lot of heartburn there the next one down
competencies did
yeah and I would just say on that one we
need to keep it as it's in statute right
now
is that d That's D yeah or else we're
going to have then the ru making
superseding
statute
keep that
says everybody just good with keeping
that y okay okay the next one down is
competency based
education for
e
well that's another one where I sort of
rewrote it
myself I wrote down and I'm echoing
what's in 193 H colon 1- a
on the purpose for performance and
accountability so it's 193 H col one-
a and I wrote down students best learn
at their own pace as they Master content
and skills allowing them to advance when
the when they demonstrate the desired
level
Mastery competencies they have
competency are explicitly stated and
measured can you imagine what we're
going to have to
do on every subject we have there's
going to be competencies and how are you
going to measure
it it's not going to be the teacher now
saying I've been trained to do that and
I recognize this child can
read but you're going to have to have
some kind of measure and it's going to
to be measured at some percentage
level I think we're opening up Pandora's
Box wasn't written by classroom teachers
that's exactly right
yeah you know the other the other um you
know so you know students students want
to learn different things and become
really good at some things maybe not
everything mhm you know and and you know
for example you know I spent a lot of
time in math and science classes you I
just really enjoyed that stuff and U and
you know I took the art classes that
that I had to take and I wish I'd
probably taken some more MH but but um
but to say that you got to move on when
you've achieved
85% I mean that's you know where how
does that cutline work for everybody
particularly if if if I really want to
be a fine arts major in college and I
want to take everything my you know I
you know you know I I'd spend all day in
the art room if I wanted if I
could you know it and you're going to
have to measure that with some kind of
an instrument let's say we're talking
about ancient history and we're talking
about the fall of the Byzantine Empire
14 00 and
something I as a teacher am not going to
expect my students to remember that date
I'm not remembering it right now but I
would like them to learn something why
the Byzantine empire fell and why that
might be relative to something that's
going on in today's world um that's the
important part I'm trying to get them to
think
logically and I think that we could get
off track here if the measurement that
the Byzantine empire fell at a certain
time yeah yeah yeah if if your takeaway
is the date the empire fell or why did
The Empire yeah fall the why is much
more important yeah yeah and the ability
the of what's the purpose for teaching
that you're trying to get the kids to
think you don't want them just scooting
off of nowhere yes but you want them
thinking and thinking asking the
question questions making those
inferences and analyzing the data so you
can know how to do that when the barbery
Pirates did their thing again with the
USS Constitution and then they did it
since when Gaddafi did his thing so does
history repeat yes it does that's what I
want to teach them and we can have we
can learn from her past all the whys and
the how's and ifs
and I'm just I I
guess I think if you're right about
something you have a question you have
to write and explain something that's
takes much more time and much more
insight than if you just answer a bunch
of questions including the dates yeah
right I agree
100% in some of these classes you judge
whether they know it by whether they can
do it they apply that
skill replace the spark PL then you
don't do that anymore do you replace a
spark plug oh yeah yeah you don't do
that anymore cars are different David
when you said move on do you mean that
you have taken X number of courses in
this particular thing and now you have
to do something different well that's
what it's that's what it's saying here
in the in at the top of um page three in
the side by side students advance to Lo
new learning opportunities upon
proficiency I mean I I'm just sort of
like taking that as as proficiency being
85% of Mastery and what if I want to
what if I want to master this
right I think that's a problem with
schooling very often that you don't have
the chance to really go into the Weeds
on one particular subject right you have
to do these other things as well because
you need so many credits and this and so
many credits and that uh yeah and that
depends on the that that depends on the
high school right um you know if you've
if you've got I mean what what do we
require
18 20 20 20 credits but some some are 22
right right but not all of them are
prescriptive to um to certain courses so
so schools that have a lot of electives
and less prescriptive you can really
dive deep into art classes or or you
know math classes
um if you look further down into 193 h1a
Roman numeral 5 it talks about the
flexibility and in learning compet
Competency Based strategies provide
flexibility in the way that credit can
be earned and awarded and provide
students with personalized
learning I think that I think that's on
P 581 581 I think addresses what you're
talking about representative luno yeah
yeah
um what did you say H5 page
five page 581 Roman numeral 5 oh in the
it's yeah 193 h one-
a in the statute book Roman five
yeah I think that's that that is what
I'm what I'm um looking for and I'm
just you know is the rule consistent
with that the proposed
rules sounds like the rules are trying
to they're trying to replicate statute
which
these statutes been around a long time
this this part
has well I guess what what I'm what I'm
taking exception to is on the on the
proposed rules on page three in the in
the first um um the middle cell on the
side by side students advance to new
learning opportunities upon proficiency
and if I think we saw proficiency is
defined at 85% of
Mastery um I'm just why why are why are
we advancing them to new learning
opportunities all good questions maybe I
want to stay in that in this learning
opportunity you can find your GI is not
going to want to get out until they have
all their answers answer might they
might want to stay in high school
forever if you're not they can't do that
so um
but but they may want to stay in the art
class um art classes as long as they
can so which page are you on right now I
where I
am yeah I was on yeah the side by side
page three top middle cell well I don't
think that necessarily means that they
have to move on to another class they
might just move on to another skill in
the same class that they're currently
yeah I mean I I agree with you but I'm
just wondering it's
it's it's sort of not it's not clear are
we trying to thread the
needle I don't know what we're trying to
do you see this this I think we're
getting into education ease this this
language
that 95% of the world don't understand
it
yeah I actually think we're getting down
into the weeds of what the teacher is
supposed to actually be doing by using
these or the curriculum providers the
curriculum planners whoever's
determining the curriculum for the
schools this is what they're supposed to
be doing based on the rules that we give
them so worrying about what when the
students actually move
along might be getting too out of our
scope I I that that's what I'm saying
yeah we're getting down Lo to the
teacher oh so you're saying this is too
prescriptive very prescriptive yeah very
I I I'm with you there
yeah okay so that was what definition
was that we were on competencies no no
we went by that uh that's the it's the
um
sorry oh that is competencies yeah okay
we were talking about competencies yeah
yeah okay so leave as is too
prescriptive
okay compy based education
uh comp competencies are explicitly
stated and
measured EXP itly
stated so we're going to have to have
curriculum writers go through
and identify all these
competencies and having the method
to assess yeah yeah no Dave gave me a
booklet on conquered High School a
listing of all the courses and all the
programs offered and the requirement
graduation require well
done and I think that's 90% making sure
the parents know and kids know and the
track they're going to be on and then
then the teacher would teach that and
when you're talking about geometry one
or whatever then it's now that math
teacher that has a credential to along
with our academic standards and later on
this report you say where are the
academic standards I've yet I don't know
where academic standards really are I
don't we haven't mhm but at any rate
it's then up to the teacher knowing here
the academic standards and hopefully
there's the Frameworks curriculum
Frameworks serve as a guide I can
develop my
instruction and measure my
instruction unless we're going to get
into what they did in the old days
Criterion reference test where the
district develops her own curriculum
tests for each subject area those didn't
last long seeing that you had to have a
bank of questions a mile long so it
wouldn't be the same question every
year I think everything has competency
we need to have a discussion with the
Department yeah okay let's move
on a course of study
means progression of competencies
leading to credit
they have of course the study means a
progression of related competencies
leading to
graduation I think that should stay as
credit if they want to change the
definition because the related
competencies would be part of one course
credit that would then with the credits
combined lead to graduation
so yeah I mean we're sort of if you look
at that book right there the old book da
there's a table
here which reflects course
the next several pages in this show
you they you see how courses are spelled
out there in that table courses with
program areas or study programs yeah so
within a program of Economics you may
have some courses which are offered the
high school right now according to this
stat rule has to have 40 at least 43
courses in their syllabus MH
and the the
courses are the you can have
competencies and you could have you
could have Mastery of that course
material or be proficient but they're
all leading towards the graduation
requirement where you have to have three
credits of this to graduate which is on
the next page with some of those tables
next couple pages
right the total of 20 credit so high
school that requires 24 credits for
graduation um would have uh well even
these 20 credits have have six open
electives so a student would be able to
apply those six to any of these courses
so here's the
I wrote trying to think how this could
be written I wrote
down a course of study is a unit of
teaching within a program of offerings
necessary to meet the requirements for
for attaining graduation
competencies so it's a course of
study is a unit of teaching within a
program of offerings well it's it's it's
really a course within yeah
it's again we're I think we're trying to
identify the nitty I I want to find that
conquered High School um U program
studies that you that that underneath
the chair where I do my work in in in
the dining room okay well no I think I
brought a stack of them in here though
yeah I think I think we've got some on
the bookshelf and they did a good job of
this Terry wolf um had a lot to do with
that and and to me that really lays out
makes it very clear what a program of
studies are is if I want to go into an
Allied Health field
um the the conquered High School um uh
course guide says for this program of
for this program these are the courses
you
take you see and this is part of what
came out of conquer right here I wrote
down for graduation competencies means
minimum credits and specific
competencies required for graduation
across a district that meet local and
state learning expectations
that came out of that conquer High
School I think we ought to Echo some of
the stuff in the field Manchester does
it too I'm just looking in in they have
pathway business marketing management
paway electives you know um possible job
opportunities it even tells them in the
course of studies what jobs they could
get if they go through that
so you see that's what we have to have
those Pathways the course of studies is
that requirements to attain that career
skill you're going after within that
pathway they have these programs set up
the program at large yeah
yeah thank you did you get one
yeah they did a very nice job
on what I was looking
at on in this thing it was
on pages six and
seven where they have graduation credit
requirements and early graduation
requirements and there's some language
in there which could be borrowed and
make things
work so you
know I think we need to put a question
mark by this one
too and maybe should be reflective on
what you know the Conqueror did
course of studies where am I here so
that would probably apply to
FG yes
mhm yeah in next one down where they
have H curriculum that should be the
definition right there in a statute MH
Department means that should be okay
differentiation that's
no is it needed
differentiation
just adjustment is made to learning
opportunities
similar I don't know I guess if you ask
five people to tell us when I met we get
five different answers there they're
getting away from from tracking
right I mean it's sort of U how is it
used later
on I don't know if we've got anything
that's searchable
well you know I looked at their
definition here to learning
opportunities for groups of Learners it
could be an individual too for an
individual or
groups of
Learners based upon learning
needs I wouldn't put similar in there
based on learning needs often times when
you have to differentiate it's because
there is a need to get off the path and
do another way
teachers do that learning style and
teaching
styles but at very least I think we need
to really address that that's not just
for groups of Learners it can be for an
individual too individual or groups of
Learners based on learning
needs I think they're doing because in
groups you want everybody in the same
group for a similar
need but
so it's used in two other places in the
um in the document it's used
on on page
39 and then on
43 and it talks about individualization
on in both those
through third so the printing on our
paper is different than the pdf version
of this I was going to say mine shows it
on 42 and 46 yeah yeah okay okay you're
good
yeah well I I I don't I'm not really
getting a heartburn on it but I'd like
to see it open up to in a smaller school
you're going to do it for an individual
not necessar a group M or you may do it
even large school you might have a
student that's come in
from Brazil and speaking
Portuguese who
knows or Manchester with 58 different
languages
yeah ready to go
on District competencies
are you back on three yeah yeah they're
removing
it I don't know why because we do have
District
offering above and beyond or they I dare
say that the competencies that one
district has fors competencies in
another district for the same course
might be different
because the state's not writing these
compes the local is unless the state
plans are doing
this if we're going to do it better find
an oil
well isn't that a problem though if you
have different districts have different
competencies so if you go one school you
learn something one way and if you move
somewhere else it's going to be
different different and it seems to me
there should be something overarching
that basic stuff is the same
everywhere you're never going to get
that you know there's some places that
in Patty's school they might teach us
history in the eighth grade and days
they may do it in the ninth grade your
school they may wait and do that in 11th
grade so then you give the
accountability test at one level if it's
done at the level you're teaching it or
the preceding year you might your kids
might do well if kids haven't had it yet
they're going to fail it so so these are
done
locally so I might want to pick a school
that teach us the way I want it yeah
this
sequence that's why we have the
opportunity for when a kid comes into
school we've had this discussion on the
education commit here often where the
receiving
school the principal will make a
decision whether they're going to accept
that credit or that credit coming in or
that course coming in
if there's a question then you can take
out your competency test and administer
that to the kid and if they do well they
get credit for the
course okay but I can remember as
represent Woodcock was objecting to that
the whole premise what we're doing just
leave it the way it
is so
um I I think they ought leave this
District's competencies in I don't know
why they're taking it out
there's District competencies there's
graduation
competencies are they saying across one
District or across all districts Common
across the district I I take that like
Manchester so that they're teaching the
same thing because kids move around
from
school make sure they're talking about
the individual District yeah
I I don't want that
removed yeah if you took that out you
could have a problem East and West
yeah we have four different high schools
yeah yeah four different middle
schools everybody in favor keeping it in
keep educator
means why do we need a definition of an
educator I put okay by it
but
okay revised language to ensure
consistency with educator credential
division are state regulations
Reed the most I'm okay to ensure
consistency by the educator
definition credential
definition so in the in the proposed
definition in k um on the second column
U are these
all certifi yeah but are these all
different things different
um different groups
administrators educational Specialists
instructional Specialists teachers par
Educators educational interpreter
translators School nurses and any other
individuals credentialed by the State
Board of
Education that's the same as was
before so why not just say an educator
is anybody that's credential by the
state board ofed education yeah and take
all the in between stuff out yeah
because K isn't really saying that yeah
K
K's yeah K's not saying
that because we have certain some Paras
are credentialed some are
not um depending upon what they're doing
so I would leave that up to Steve
applebe to make that decision he's doing
it his bureau is to department is doing
that I would write it educator means any
individual credential by the State Board
of
Education so is an uh just to um you
know poke on this a little bit is an ed
does an educ include the
superintendent
administrator well no just going with
your definition yeah Rick
um credentialed by the State Board of
Ed we have it where principales and
administrators are considered teachers
somewhere in law I can't remember where
it is
hey I I have I don't think it's a big
enough thing to get hung up on yeah I
don't either and but there but you know
an administrator doesn't fall under the
same definition as a teacher I don't
think well that's why I would say
Educators means any individuals
credential by the State Board of
Education so then how how's the word
educator used in in here can or can
Educators do any you
know this is a type of thing that
belongs in law not in a
rule yeah yeah I think it is yeah like
like we have it in law that
superintendents have these
responsibilities building
principles we're getting a little bit
out of our domain to our
responsibilities of academic standards
here yeah yeah
yeah so want to belabor this anymore
this one I like the definition you posed
but I think let's come back to it when
we take a look at how educator gets
used well it's something we can throw
back at them and then have them explain
yeah okay
okay okay next one
Equity is something new
they took out the term also includes
equitable
that was the
change I don't know why do we need that
I was going to say isn't it similar to
differentiation that definition
adjustments made to learning
opportunities for groups of Learners
based on that and they're talking about
grp groupings of
individuals in equity it seems like the
same thing differentiation seems to
cover what they're trying to do here
with
Equity I mean
if every student is required to have
access to an
free and
uh appropriate public education then
isn't that Equity
already no that's that's not
equity so they're talking about a kid
that's let's see not being placed at the
level that they need to be placed at
because they have already accomplished
these skills and knowledge on level two
or three and yet they're in class three
or level three but they should be really
getting four now is that Equity when
they're not providing that opportunity
for competency for that
child being held back rather than going
forward I mean I think that I think that
could be and actually
and and I I think what Katie was talking
about could be e could be Equity too but
but I think also if you've got a student
that is um that has has trouble hearing
having a classroom that has a um you
know audio FM system that that makes um
uh makes it easier to
hear the
teacher and providing students that that
have um difficult time hearing with the
equipment for that I think that's
inequity so then why are is that child
getting referred for special
services I don't know
yeah I think we're widening these rules
out but notice JL car's um comment on
this yeah is very
interesting to individuals or groups of
individuals based on their identified
needs in order to adjust for
non-achievement of competencies for
other barriers to
success it's all coming down to this
competencies thing it's you know so if a
kids not place where they
belong why aren't
they they they guess they've reflected
on the recommendation of Jael
car want to go on Beyond this or leave
it yeah I'm I'm going to circle the the
Jael car piece because I think maybe um
maybe just eliminating the definition
and going with
the going with the common use
obviously if they're following the
definition of
competencies some of that wouldn't
occur next one down is Extended Learning
opportunities for
I don't know if it has to be out outside
the classroom could be in the classroom
too or in the school I don't know
through means outside the
classroom I don't know why I think the
the the current rule uses that type of
language too um
yeah so so Rick going back to com just
going back to competencies in general
yeah is there a list of competencies
that that lead to graduation or is it
courses or El you know courses that lead
to graduation each of those courses has
competencies yeah that that that latter
part you said is correct there there's
courses
that are part of a program area a
program of study like you know and you
have to have X number
credits for graduation in each of those
areas including I think six electives or
so yeah and so and an ELO could be an
elective yes or it could be or it could
be addressing one of the um the 14
required see this is getting a little
bit into where Patty's involved with
Career Technical education where we've
now allowed provided that if there's an
agreement between the sending district
and the CTE the board and the
CTE that through that CTE program you
could get credit for chemistry if those
competencies established by the local
District are immersed into the program
at the CTE Center that's in law right
now right but it would have to be all of
those
competencies we it's been set up by this
for the CTE that as long as during the
course of study in that program M they
may not get all the competencies within
this one course over there they may get
it in another course at the CT Center
but they're going to end up with all the
comp compes for that credit M I think
it's a great idea that saves
Transportation MH
so I guess I'm I'm not going to get hung
up on that
either that allows for achievement of
compeny through means outside the
classroom I think just the word allows
means that you don't have to but if you
do it's
okay you have a a choice an opportunity
to do something outside the classroom
I don't know yeah I've been I can
remember that when I was in Alaska I had
this family that had this large Schooner
and they went around the world MH and
they want to know could we take our
child with us and we laid out what he
was going to get navigation and
Mathematics and weather and and
geography and all that and it came out
that following this and Reporting in
accordance with how we set it up kid was
going to get credit and through that
experience so that was an Extended
Learning
opportunity I think we have we've been
doing this for for years and years and
years oh yeah it's nothing new it may be
ear that Alternative Learning learn
everywhere M probably is but private
instruction independent study
internships that's something for example
the kids at Lisbon are doing with New
England wire right now they're going in
and getting some of that mathematics on
the floor of New England wire you should
see that plan up there they're building
a huge wing on it they're they're
selling stuff in France right now this
it's fine
wire um community service
apprenticeships I don't know if you need
all those things listed underneath it
but oh they took all those out yeah oh
they took that out yeah okay that's
good is that okay with everybody M okay
let's
go graduation competencies
they removed
this
why I guess why was it in there before
how is it being
used graduation competencies say 59
references
well lot this doesn't have anything to
do with academic
standards want to jump by this one
graduation competencies I I have a
question mark I'm wondering why they
want to take it out yeah I think it's a
well they've taken it out every it seems
like in most of the places it's used
too and it's
um I would say some of the graduation
competencies that conquered High have
are much different than Woodsville high
school and they may have more
requirements for graduation then another
one um that's
local I think it's just ask why
out
individualization see it gets pretty
when you get in this
individualization trying to Define that
why are we doing that
as I'm jumping through the search it
shows that oh let's see what page is
this page 11 graduation competencies the
note the commentary shows that it was
removed and replaced with graduation
competencies in the new 8306 point21 so
it just might all be moved
elsewhere I haven't gotten that far yet
mhm and then instruction means the act
or practice of
teaching instruction means deliberate
and strategic approaches to facilitate
student learning strategic
approaches what the hell is that mean
teaching pardon me I don't know it's not
teaching deliberate approaches to take
student
Le it's kind of taking the teaching out
of
it
yeah you see some Master Teachers just
doing things and they're able to change
gears and move to another level so
quickly and be so effective in doing
that because they caught the
moment and it was just a natural thing
it's all about engaging
students but yeah
this but also this moves it from
teaching to facilitating yeah it takes
the role of the teacher it's getting rid
of
teacher say that again that because
that's kind of scary well
the practice of teaching and strategic
approaches to facilitating student
learning who's doing that it doesn't say
it has to be a
teacher who is
it it's just like I asked out at Warren
Village School the school was a school
of excellence this year I asked the
principal Mike how are they delivering
Speech Pathology out here it's being
done online from
California so the second grader that's
trying to learn how to say
R is getting that from somebody in
California on a screen that's speech
therapy who is not a New Englander who
doesn't know yeah that doesn't
understand it's ours natural that's
right or however you say
it so you can be a
facilitator this is what competencies
does it ends up you teacher becomes a
manager of forms and all this other
stuff and you have a parent coming in
off the street doing the
teaching doing the facilitating yeah
facil and you're not getting the same
quality but I think a teacher has a lot
of different kinds of skills and if they
can pick up something and work
strategically to teach a kid when they
have the right moment me I don't think
why you have to have a different term
for it the facilitator I think your
teacher can be an excellent facilitator
I'd like to know why we're defining
it I got to go and get some water yeah
yeah I got to be out of here another
half hour
so got I'll get down
south what page are we on right now
four at the beginning me I said I got
the page five six I totally frustrated
and threw it
away and I've tried this six or seven
different times only on page for yeah
yeah see once we got by the definitions
though then a lot of stuff's not our
responsibility unless you're on that
rules thing then it is
so does our other committee have to meet
and look at this too well we're all here
right
now this cat's not coming
in I always wonder about the people on
jail car who have to read these things
and have to pick you know you know who's
done all this on on Jael car they're
attorneys yeah yeah I know yeah there
are four of them that sit there listen
to them I'm I'm sit on so I listen to
them where they describe you know this
is not clear this is clear something
doesn't have the then go back and for I
said how do you get to sit down and do
those
things it is so
picky
yeah okay so
instruction means the act of practicing
practice of
teaching now they changed it to
instruction means deliberate and
strategic approaches to facilitate
student learning I don't like
that I like that instruction means the
act of engaging ing students in learning
activities
okay which one we're going to go through
the initial
proposal proposed unapproved
revisions or none of the above where are
you now instruction
instruction the actual practice of
teaching yeah yes yeah okay okay next
one down instructional time means the
period of time during which instruction
is
offer seems pretty
intuitive yeah you used to have time on
task and all that other stuff
though you know you might be sitting in
the class for instruction 40 minutes but
you might only be working for 20
minutes okay although although k k um um
in in the current administrative rule I
think has a broader definition than
instructional
time
um during which instruction is offered
means the act or practice of teaching
working towards achieving educ outcom
under the supervision of an educator or
other staff
member you were back in instructional
time again yeah well I thought we said
okay means a period of time during which
instruction is offered who's who's
offering the
instruction could be a sub to a
teacher could be uh the custodian yeah
yeah I mean that that's in the current
term under the supervision of an
educator or other staff member yeah um
and it's during which pupils are
actively working towards achieving
educational objectives
um so they might be working on a a
project with a team or something like
that under the supervision of a of a
teacher and that would still be
considered instructional time as opposed
to the
U the direct instruction see the first
first definition we have in place right
now would be applicable to a high school
that has a study hall and the kids go
for a study hall for 45
minutes but there is somebody in the
supervising and if have a question you
go ask the person now you don't
understand this so you're being
supervised and you're receiving
instruction time
MH time now the next one in time which
you're actually receiving instruction
during which instruction is offered see
offered there's a catch word right there
yeah so I I like the original I do too
yeah okay race that out that's I got a
pencil going on down Mastery means a
high level of
demonstrated I think it's underneath my
thing here proficiency with regard to a
competency and they're removing
that because they don't like the word
Mastery that's what's they're against
that
you can see the discussion on the next
page on
that and when you go back to the
definition of competencies it says
competency means student learning
targets that represent a level of
Mastery of key content specific concept
skills and knowledge applied within or
across content domains
that doesn't explain what Mastery is
well they're defining it on the next
page means the student performance
required to achieve at least 85% of a
competency I think this comes underneath
our discussion we want to have talk
about proficiency competency and Mastery
yeah yeah
okay okay more
discussion um next one learning level
means the students identify Readiness to
receive instruction and a
competency the jel car said this seems
to be in conflict with the new
definition of
Competency but not with the old one not
with a statutory
definition students identified Readiness
to receive instruction in a
competency is that um so this is going
back to my time on Schoolboard what was
it was there something called proximate
zone
of I don't know
yeah look it
up but it had to do with the
students readiness
proxim proxim if we can get through the
definitions today I think we got quit
after
definitions that means another page
other than where we are the zone of
proximal development is a concept in
educational psychology that describes a
gap between what a learner can do
independently what they can achieve with
help or with yeah
vosi
yeah see I remembered something
I'm looking at that Lo level
they receive
instruction accept instruction absorb
instruction understand the instruction
given I can receive a lot of things that
this mean that I have
a understanding of it
MH yeah I know when I was in school it
all flew over my head
oh I'm
ready yeah I think learn I think this
part requires more
work learning level
M
yep and you know for for something
that's you know with a very short
definition there if you don't get that
right
yeah I mean that's that maybe the most
important
thing yeah I think that needs a lot of
work
yeah learn opportunities means
educational experiences including but
not limited to
online I think that all that needs work
mhm okay
if you're on the next page it's F page
five on mine
but I'm looking at the one that says
proficiency means the minimum student
performance required to satisfy
achievement of ACC
compy are you see where where P portion
size just above
it MH
I think we need to have a discussion on
this where people have requested that
proficiency be changed to
Mastery
but I think compeny proficiency Mastery
all need more
work the
need ex definitions that cannot be
confused
I like know how they came up at 85%
too master should be closer to
100 yeah if you want to have Mastery
something you want a roofer knows how to
do it not 85%
what rigor means the depth of which the
demonstration of complies is measured oh
that's already in statutory
language 193
e2a no I guess is
not
rhetoric
logic for
under the work study practices that is a
statutory
definition but jelar is saying consider
defining these three terms separately
using their statutory
definitions I think their proposed
response is work studies practice means
work study practices is defined in the
law I think doe got that one right
I think we're getting pretty tired at
least I am I think where we got to go
next is
that there's a section coming up 306.000
3 statutory and policy
requirements I'm kind of shocked that
we're now getting into business writing
policy on the state
level um when we've been doing that
locally I think we got to be very
careful where we're going what's the
responsibility of the school
board
um the other other issues that I you
know would like to look at um there's a
number of places where they put down and
listed the areas that make up the
substant criteria for an adequate
education um on my it's on page
11 and they've sliced down and they for
example they just say Arts education and
law says Arts education including music
and visual arts they've not put the
whole thing down um personal finance
literacy is not even
mentioned um on health education they
put health education it's Health and
Wellness
um and then they broken out US History
New Hampshire history us and New
Hampshire government Civics economics
including personal finance world
history its social studies including
geography history economics Civics and
government um so they're they're kind of
rewriting a lot of
this and I I think we ought to be very
careful that because that comes into the
domain we're responsible for that's
getting into
19328 MH and that's our thing they can't
change
that without approval well they can't
change it it has to be changed by
General Court that's the only way it can
change right
now and so they're changing some of this
stuff I think those are the things we
really got to catch and say we got to
maintain our statutory definitions and
look at the content areas in the subst
criteria for an adequate education as
written in statute
you see the the comment here removed
what and replaced with graduation
requirements in
83611 so they put it somewhere else but
I don't know if they put the whole thing
there
yeah another catch I caught on page 10
they say Wellness as required by section
204 it should be health and wellness
MH any other comments for
today what is the next meeting I don't
know
I guess we got to find
out they have 10 years to renew these
things last down 2015 so means 2025 that
that's in accordance with what they
renewed the contract for the third party
to right with with with the
competency organization um
and you know and there's no reason to
run head you know straight into the wall
with with rules that continue need work
because they can ex the jail card can
extend they can extend and there's
probably going to be a lot of changes
beyond what we got in front of us
yeah somewhere along the way I'd like to
have a discussion with them on these
three
terms compy proficiency where are we
going and really get in discussion as
far
as how deep down in each subject area
you're going to have competency written
now who's going to do it what's it going
to cost um
are we going back to where I can
remember there was a program called
Fountain Valley and it was a Reading
literature program where it listen every
skill for reading you could imagine and
the teacher had to check that off in
every kid in class all day long I was
recording and you a good teacher if you
were able to get them all
recorded not what your teaching so it's
you know I don't want to go back there
right I think that'd be taking a little
bit away from the teachers that we are
hopefully coming in with these skills
already you know ah
Hadad
so so when do you think we ought meet
again i' not don't want to meet a whole
lot in the summertime on that stuff no I
think it's just P's
pool yeah you have a
s uh well you don't meet in July right
is that sort of a a rule July and August
July and August
August yeah no meetings July and August
yeah
okay that's right that's all okay by me
so sometime in September yeah yeah and
we'll find out where we where they are
by that time Jennifer's not even here
she's out in Utah today right she's at a
conference she had a conference out
there is she going to ncsl I don't know
I know
there turn the mics off for a second
um
e for